this is how it begins when individuals
join a regulated profession they do not
lose their Charter right to freedom of
expression at the same time however they
take on obligations and must abide by
the rules of their regulatory body that
may limit their freedom of expression
that's just one sentence after another
that's how it starts yeah yeah perfect
it's a great thing to highlight you know
it's well you have this fundamental
right
but well but what what rules there's
what there's a rule a there's a rule is
that right that the College of
psychologists has that I can't criticize
Justin Trudeau on Twitter that's a rule
is it and if someone anywhere in the
world complains about the fact that I
have criticized Justin Trudeau let's say
that all of a sudden that's a rule even
though it wasn't a rule and of course I
get to criticize Justin Trudeau not only
because he richly deserves it in every
way you can possibly imagine but because
that's actually what freedom of speech
means